digamos que administramos una granja de
gallinas ponedoras y ayer salimos y
recolectamos 398 huevos de las gallinas
y hoy recolectamos 251 huevos de las
gallinas y lo que nos interesa es saber
cuántos huevos tenemos aproximadamente
ahora que los hemos recolectado en los
últimos dos días bueno hay algunas
maneras en que podríamos hacer eso
podríamos simplemente sumar 398 y 251 y
averiguar cuál es el resultado pero
digamos que no tenemos mucho tiempo y no
tenemos papel y queremos hacerlo en la
mente y no nos importa el número exacto
queremos saber aproximadamente cuántos
huevos tenemos bueno aquí es donde la
herramienta de estimación es muy útil
entonces en lugar de decir la cantidad
exacta de huevos podríamos decir cuántos
tenemos aproximadamente y eso es lo que
significa este signo de igual ondulado
significa que no tenemos que obtener el
número exacto pero cuántos tenemos
aproximadamente de modo que lo estaremos
estimando
que podemos hacer esto es redondear cada
uno de estos números a un número cercano
pero que sea más fácil de sumar en la
mente y luego sumar esos dos números
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo
por su cuenta antes de hacerlo juntos
muy bien hagámoslo juntos comencemos con
398 y dejen de redondearlo a la decena
más cercana entonces en él 398 tenemos
un 9 en el lugar de las decenas pero
puedes verlo como 39 decenas más 8 la
decena que está justo abajo es
exactamente 39 decenas y 0 unidades o
390 y luego la siguiente decena es 40
decenas lo que es igual a 400 ahora a
cual de escena redondear y amos bueno
398 está más cerca de 400 que de 390 y
hemos hablado en los vídeos de redondeo
que pueden ver si esto de aquí es igual
a 5 o más por lo que redondearía mos a
la siguiente decena hacia arriba
entonces redondear y amos
cientos de 398 los redondeamos a 400 y
luego le sumamos 251 a que es igual si
lo redondeamos a la decena más cercana
lo voy a hacer de este lado 251 la
decena que está debajo es igual a 250 y
la decena que está justo arriba es igual
a 260 una vez más puedes ver esto como
25 decenas más 1 y 251 está claramente
más cerca de 250 podemos redondear hacia
abajo otra forma de hacerlo es fijarnos
en la posición de las decenas y luego
fijarnos en la posición de las unidades
y decir este es menor que 5 así que voy
a redondear hacia abajo a la posición de
las decenas y así obtenemos 250 entonces
cuando redondea 251 a la decena más
cercana obtendrás 250 ahora te invito a
sumar estos dos en tu mente cuál es el
resultado
bueno hay muchas maneras diferentes de
abordar esta suma pero podríamos decir
que vamos a pensar en las centenas tengo
cuatro centenas y le voy a sumar dos
centenas déjenme hacer esto en un color
nuevo entonces si tengo cuatro centenas
le estoy sumando dos centenas bueno eso
es igual a seis centenas y si tengo cero
decenas y le estoy sumando cinco decenas
bueno todavía tendré cinco decenas y
luego cero unidades en los dos casos así
que seguiré teniendo cero unidades y ahí
lo tienes
pudimos estimar que 398 más 251 son
aproximadamente 650 hasta el próximo
vídeo